donald trump et eti hier au pied du mur
le président américain s'est rendu dans
la vallée du rio grande est le but de
cette visite célébrer le 450e miles soit
le sept cents 24e kilomètre de son mur à
la frontière mexicaine
l'oeuvre de son mandat censé stopper
l'immigration illégale venus du mexique
une promesse de campagne que donald
trump estime avoir réalisé
mais contrairement à ceux qui sont venus
avant moi j'ai tenu mes promesses et
aujourd'hui nous célébrons un jalon
extraordinaire l'achèvement des 450
matches de murs frontières promis 450
miles la sécurité de notre nation doit
passer avant la politique
nous avons de nombreux désaccords dans
le pays mais nous devrions tous convenir
de la nécessité urgente de sécuriser nos
frontières de protégez notre patrie et
de permettre aux forces de l'ordre de
remplir leur mission sans ingérence
politique
mais en réalité ce ne sont pas 724 mais
seulement 128 kilomètres de murs qui
serait sorti de terre sous
l'administration trump le reste ne sont
que des rénovations apportées aux
travaux de ses prédécesseurs george bush
et bill clinton
contrairement à ses promesses de
candidat ce sont bien les états unis qui
paie aujourd'hui la facture et elle
s'élève à près de 18 milliards de
dollars
un mur dont les travaux pourraient
rapidement s'arrêter l'administration
byden l'a déjà promis plus 1 km de murs
ne sera construit